if like you think that some external
achievement is gonna make you happy
you're gonna get it and you're gonna
realize that it's not gonna make you
happy until you actually start to get
the things that you're striving for
you're not gonna realize that they
aren't gonna make you happy so I almost
feel like everybody needs to learn the
tactics and the techniques and get the
tools to actually get what they're
aiming for so like if you want to get
some level of financial wealth and you
think that's gonna make you happy and
you just want that well the best way to
transcend that is to actually get it I
don't know how you do it unless you
actually get it and then when you get it
then you're like I gotta figure out some
other things that'll work I'm joined by
Aubry Marcus founder and CEO of on it
fellow podcaster and all-around
fascinating human Aubrey welcome to the
show thanks brother happy to be here
very very happy to have you on I'm sure
there'll be a lot of people that are
familiar with what it is that you do but
how do you describe what it is that you
do on a daily basis and your life to
someone who's never met you before yeah
it's an interesting thing I mean
obviously you can describe the things
that I've done you know in my personal
history that I've accomplished
you know founded the company on it you
know wrote the book on the day done the
Aubrey Marcus podcasting that I've done
but really if you're talking about me as
a person I'm just someone who's trying
to learn a little bit more today that'll
make me a little bit better tomorrow
than I am today you know so just someone
who's on the path of learning in the
path of exploring in the path of asking
questions and trying to figure out the
small questions and the big questions
isn't that interesting that when asked
that one of the first things that we
default to is our achievements
quantifiable metrics of status mm-hmm
yeah I mean that's what that's what the
typical response to that question is you
know like what is it who what's your job
like what have you done like what are
your what are your validations it's it's
reinforcing you're somebody Ness you
know as some of the spiritual teachers
say like this is what makes you somebody
you founded a company you wrote a book
you have a podcast you have this
no wife you have this thing you have
these kids you have this is your
somebody 'no Swan Leavitt of expression
of course and that's all fine but the
really interesting thing is like who are
you and how close are you becoming to
the truth of who and what you are and
how you serve you know that's that's a
really much more interesting question
for me at least but you know the other
stuff is trying to I think it's
interesting for me as well but it's a
little bit less sexy and easy to get out
in a cocktail party or like when you sat
in a table eh yeah it's you have to suss
out the audience you know like yeah you
got to figure out who's gonna who's
gonna care about those those more
interesting issues and who's just gonna
want to talk about the same old stuff
you know like and that's that's kind of
the people I like to surround myself
with people that we can immediately
bypass past the banal recounting of the
the personal history you know like that
alright that happened I can tell you
what happened but uh but that's not
what's interesting what's more
interesting is what's happening you know
like how is not who abri was but what is
the Aubrey Inge that's going on right
now the verb to Aubrey exactly yeah it's
again it's it's so interesting because
it's easy for people to have a
conversation let's say someone maybe has
quite subtle or contrary views or they
fall on the ends of the distribution for
whatever normality is that they have
things in common in the way that they
think or the way that they speak about
everything with other people and they
have to choose whether they want to be
honest or they want to be acceptable and
not that game of how much should I open
up and as you've alluded to one of the
key words is truth speaking your truth
forward being as virtuous as you can
living with integrity and acting the
logos if you go in Jordan Peterson with
it and it's easy to see why people start
to take on these personas right they
start to get addicted to the
acceptability and they forget the honest
until they don't know what honesty looks
like anymore it's a bad trap because the
persona is incapable of actually
receiving love it can receive praise but
you're not going to feel it because it's
not you you know what I mean it's like
and when people I think it's one of the
reasons that like actors have a problem
right like people may love the character
that they played and that may make them
love that that person when they see them
but the actor is just playing a
character so you know you can be
appreciated for your craft as an actor
but that person is not actually gonna
feel loved you know because they know
they're being loved for being gladiator
you know they're nothing loved for being
like yeah yeah it's not it's not that
people are loving Russell Crowe they're
loving [ __ ] Maximus you know what I
mean and so we're all playing our own
version of Maximus and then showing
people this thing and then people are
loving that thing but it's not actually
landing so we're actually denying
ourselves the ability to have that
genuine human connection that we really
crave and really being seen unless we
lead with our vulnerability you know I
mean that's the that's the key thing
that's gonna allow us to really feel all
the good stuff do you find yourself
obviously as you've mentioned there are
quantifiable metrics of success that can
be ascribed to you to define you as
those begin to mount up and continue to
mount up does it feel sometimes like
baggage that you then need to release to
not identify yourself with those things
you know I think I I think I do uh I
think I can get stuck in little sticky
traps for sure but I think my sticky
traps are the the traps of kind of
binding myself to a certain expectation
of progress an expectation of doing more
it's not that I'm like it's not that I
have to shed the the baggage of the past
because I almost do that automatically
like oh I did that yesterday whatever
that doesn't that was that was yesterday
like I don't really celebrate the things
that have happened in the past I'm
always looking
towards the new thing and so that's
actually where I have more of a
challenge you know it's like I they and
you know I got the I got the text and
the call that owned the day on your life
was a New York Times bestseller which is
something that I really was
congratulation what happened yeah thank
you so so when that happened though I
took like one minute to be like that's
pretty cool and then like immediately
like I didn't give a [ __ ] and I was
hunting the next thing you know what I
mean so it wasn't like so for me it's
about slowing down a little bit and not
trying to think about what the next
thing is and just being able to like be
at peace with where I'm at now as well
as have that ambition to continue to go
and to continue to offer my you know
what I have to give to the world so yeah
for me it's a little bit of a different
challenge it's not so much that I'm I
need to let go of the past cuz I feel
like I don't even take that in anyways
it's like oh that happened whatever but
it's like what am i doing now yeah and
that's where I get stuck baggage from
the future bizarre yeah exactly
not baggage right past that's
interesting so I wonder whether or not
the writing process of when you were
writing your book of whether you were
more consumed with the idea of writing a
good book and of potentially becoming a
New York Times bestseller and then when
it happened it was that okay like that's
that's done it's not bizarre there are
conscientiousness and our
industriousness our desire to continue
to feel like we're moving forward is
almost that is what we're working toward
rather than the achievement itself the
achievement comes and goes yeah totally
you know it's like and that's why if you
get stuck and that's the only thing that
you're you think is gonna make you happy
if like you think that some external
achievement is gonna make you happy
you're gonna get it and you're gonna
realize that it's not gonna make you
happy and I think it's it's a it's one
of those things that until you actually
start to get the things that you're that
you're striving for you're not gonna
realize that they aren't gonna make you
happy so I almost feel like everybody
needs to learn the tactics and the
techniques and get the tools to actually
get what they're aiming
so like if you want to get some some
level of financial wealth and you think
that's gonna make you happy and you just
want that well the best way to transcend
that is to actually get it you know if
you think that writing a best-selling
book is gonna make you happy like the
best way to realize that it's not gonna
make you happy is to get it you know
it's like I don't know how you do it
unless you actually get it and then when
you get it then you're like [ __ ] some
things that'll work and that's the
process of kind of like retraining
yourself and I think that's a process
that I'm in now is I still enjoy the
things I do and that's great because I'm
very fortunate that I've chosen things
that I love I love podcasting I love
writing I love running on it but
nonetheless I recognize that no external
validation no external thing is actually
going to make me happy it's the internal
work that's gonna actually level me up
into a place where I have a deeper
satisfaction and a deeper engagement
with the world there's an interesting
that we kind of need to close that loop
and that's a suggestion from yourself
because I think a lot of the time
speaking to people who are quite
spiritually minded there is a there can
be quite a aloofness or people on a high
horse about the fact that you should
just be able to let go of your
attachments or let go of your desires to
achieve certain things whereas your
coming up from an even more industrious
perspective which is okay bringing the
thing that you think is going to make
you happy and it was sharp a contrast as
you can ie make it happen yup and then
go from there I think that's a really
interesting way and it's a much more
fine final way it's a proper full stop
once you I agree man and I just I wish I
wish that I could believe that somebody
could actually let this [ __ ] go without
hat without doing it I just I don't
think I've ever really seen it you know
because like I've seen people pretend
like I've seen a lot of spiritual people
pretend like I don't care about money
you know like money doesn't matter and
then the minute we engage in some kind
of business deal you know they get all
squirrely and get all weird and
like whoa like everything's cool you're
gonna get paid like relaxed you know so
I've never actually seen it's almost
like they're they're spiritually
bypassing is you know the word they're
spiritually bypassing they're egoic
desires for something and pretending
that they don't want it or changing the
game to change the rules but I've never
actually seen it work the only time I've
really seen it work is when someone
actually gets that thing that they're
aiming for trains themselves has the
skills learns the practice gives the to
10,000 hours to actually get that and
then gets it and then realize like okay
I got that and it didn't quite work so
now what's the next thing it can't be
more the same yes it's almost like it's
almost like Buddha right like with
Buddha have been able to be Buddha if he
didn't grow up in the palace and I if he
didn't grow up in the palace of luxury
and feasts and sex and orgies and if he
was outside the palace walls he might
have been like man if I could just get
in that palace and have a couple feasts
and a couple threesomes man I'll be
happy yeah you know and then Buddha
never would have existed but because he
grew up with that and realized that that
didn't make him happy then he went
outside the palace walls and was like no
no no like that didn't work I did that
thing I was not happy you know now I'm
doing this thing sitting under the Bodhi
tree and I'm happy as [ __ ] you know like
so it's it's interesting and it's uh I'm
definitely open to other ways for people
to you know engage in the path but I
think the most reliable thing is to just
work to get those things that you want
and when you get those things that you
want you'll be ready to take the next
step of the journey which is to realize
that there's more to life than getting
these external you know achievements mmm
yeah it's a very very interesting way to
look at it so one of the things that I
wanted to discuss today was what you
think a good life looks like and we've
already touched on that not necessarily
doing things for their sake doing them
because they feel like something that's
valuable to you not doing them for
external validation but how do you
define a good life what does a good life
look like to you
ah I think a good life is a life that
leaves it's a life that the signature
that life is something that you've
experienced you've really lived
you've really first of all you have to
really live life you know I think the
ascetics the people who've like denied
the pleasures of the body and been in a
path of renunciation where they're just
kind of isolating themselves or going to
a monastery I respect that path but I
don't think that to me is the path that
most of us should take I think we're
here to live on the earth to really
experience all the things to eat the
food to try the drinks to try the you
know to try the drugs not all the not
all the drugs but some of them at least
rogues select drugs yeah like it's like
do the things don't abuse them you know
like don't go you don't go wild but like
experience all the things like go visit
the beautiful places like dip in a cold
water fall and feel rain fall on your
face and you know go to a hot desert and
climb a snowy mountain and do all of
these things surf and ski and play and
dance and make love and and do all the
things that we're here to do I think
think that's a big part of it it's just
to open yourself up to that I think
another part is to feel our connection
you know spiritually to everything
around us to that source energy the
universe God if you promise your
language permits it whatever your
language permits you to feel as far as a
spiritual experience I think that's a
unique expression of what we're able to
do here so it's both the carnal and the
spiritual it's the physical and the
astral kind of dancing together and then
the other thing is to just make sure
that you've left the world and everybody
you've touched a little better for you
having been here and I think that's the
commitment to service you know so
experience everything but also leave
everybody that you touch and everybody
every place that you go a little more
enriched and a little more colorful and
and vibrant then then when you found it
and if you do that and that's a good
life to me it's really nice guy
principles I think an interesting thing
there again
one thing that appears to be a defining
characteristic of what you're talking
about here is agency and not inertia not
necessarily being an ascetic as you
suggested not the relinquish enough
things but the the movement the
direction towards those things a body at
motion stays at motion it continues to
collect and move through these
experiences and these adventures I
wonder how many people that lean toward
a spiritual life and say that they are
satisfied with simple things that they
only need some people take pride in how
little stimulus they need to be happy
and again as you've suggested there's
some spiritual leaders and some master
meditators for whom that's amazing but I
wonder how many other people are kidding
themselves into believing that because
it is a very easy way to not have to
push for many things in life and to
allow yourself to settle a much lower
setpoint of experience and adventure I'd
say most of them you know I say may be
asking me like what's the ratio I'd say
that's most people you know I think we
it's uh we're afraid we're afraid to
acknowledge what we want were afraid to
acknowledge what's possible because then
we're afraid we might fail we're afraid
we might not get it so it's easier to
just pretend like I don't care about any
of that you know like yeah it doesn't
matter to me because that's just
changing the value structure so that
you're the ego can win at a certain
level that the ego doesn't feel like it
can win at the other level but it's
really it's ultimately the pursuit of
the thing that's that's always the most
enjoyable anyways and then I think
there's a great satisfaction in getting
getting yourself better at whatever it
is that you can do you know and so yeah
I mean I think it's most people who are
who are kidding themselves when they're
saying that they don't want these things
they don't want I think we do want these
things it's part of life and it doesn't
have to be fancy like I mean you don't
have to have a Ferrari like that's like
not necessary but like a nice car
there's lots of nice cars
it might be nice to have a nice car like
a vehicle a mechanical vehicle that like
you're like yeah I [ __ ] like this
thing you know you like you don't have
to set your sights on some super fancy
you know
Bentley ghost or whatever the fun-run
amaz yeah yeah exactly just like it's
just like but but know that like no I I
want a nice car and I want like a
comfortable house that has like I want
to own my own place and I want to like
you know one day I want to have a
threesome you know and like whatever
that whatever your thing is you know it
is you've just taken the words out of my
mouth not threesome but one of the fans
of the show Jordan I know he's also a
fan of yours he once told me the story
about why he I don't know whether he's
got a written list but I know that he
has a bunch of desires that he wants to
fulfill sexually like to have sex with a
Brazilian girl and to have sex with a
dis girl and have sex with her that girl
and it comes back to the open loops we
were talking about earlier on and he
said that he wants once he settled down
with his wife-to-be and he's starting to
build a family he wants to be able to
walk past a Brazilian girl in the street
and not think I wonder what it's like to
[ __ ] a Brazilian girl it's like if you
don't if you don't do that I mean it
would be like imagining imagining like a
certain type of fruit is forbidden like
watermelon is forbidden right and then
you you could because you've made an
agreement with somebody that you can no
longer ever have watermelon well that
might be fine if you've had a lot of
watermelon in your life you're like I
know watermelon it's pretty good but
like I'm good like I can remember what
that's like but can you imagine can you
imagine walking by a watermelon
everybody's on a hot summer day just
pouring salt on it and like oh you
stripping down their mouth and you're
like god I can't even [ __ ] try that
thing that really is bugging me you know
what I mean like and that's I think I
think the that's the thing like get out
there and live like really live
especially before you get in a situation
that's going to restrict your ability to
do that and and I think there's lots of
benefits people think I'm like this open
relationship champion I'm not it has
tons of perils and tons of challenges
and it's a very hard path but I think
it's it is important to like have a lot
of experiences like your friend says so
that if you do get in a situation where
you are restricting some of the option
that you might have that you understand
like that you've gone out there and
you've lived and that you know you know
largely what the landscape of everything
looks like do you think you'll be
non-monogamous for the rest of your life
or have you not got an agenda at the
moment you know it's a really
interesting question right now sorry
about that that's uh the dog gets really
excited when somebody comes you do it
know when someone talks about
non-monogamy is that what you know it's
a really interesting question I mean
right now I'm not in any any like
labeled relationship but and so we're
exploring like what this framework of
not having any particular relationship
structure looks like and even with even
with Whitney who I've gone from
monogamous to open to then we separated
to now we're in this kind of unlabeled
experience where we're enjoying each
other and just experiencing what it's
like to have a relationship beyond
expectation and beyond labels and it's
really interesting but the experiment is
just continuing and and there's
opportunities to explore and learn and
expectations do creep up and challenges
still do creep up but it seems like
we're able to move through them faster
now than we were when we had a structure
and it was like the structure was almost
like a velcro wall and all of our
insecurities were like tennis balls and
every time we'd lob something up that
gets stuck you know but now we were
still lobbing our own insecurities and
our own stuff up and our own aversions
and our own stuff but it's not really
sticking to anything so we're able to
kind of move through things a little bit
faster but I don't know what the I don't
know what the next phase is beyond this
because I'm still just right in this one
right now where this is a another
interesting structure so so from Mahna
from seeing their single there's
monogamy there's open relationship and
there's no relationship and perhaps
there's even celibacy that's something
that I'm contemplating as well like a
elongated period of celibacy to see
what that's like what is it like when
you remove that you know sexual
expression from your life and explore
that and then I don't know what the next
phase beyond that would be yeah yeah I'm
really I'm really open and that's I
think that that's I think the thing
that's the only message that I would
give is to just not feel like there's
only one way just be curious be open to
explore always be looking and asking the
questions like is this serving me in the
best way possible and what am i learning
from this and that's what I'm gonna
continue to do and where that takes me
you know who knows I have to say I did a
conversation on non-monogamy not long
ago and there's a part of that I
couldn't I couldn't help but be
viscerally visceral relaxed reactions as
someone explained to me the the real
finer workings of how different types of
non-monogamous relationships occur and I
could feel my I don't know whether you
want to call it programming there's a
debate here about whether it's
programming or whether it's inbuilt
right but whatever that is that responds
to thinking about what would happen if
you allowed someone that you cared into
about your own not requests but your own
allowance to be physical with somebody
else or to have feelings for some cetera
etc all of these different ways that he
pieces together and I honestly think
that that sounds more difficult than
celibacy but I haven't tried either so I
can't I can't speak just yet yeah I mean
there is there's nothing I mean and I've
done every different psychedelic every
different sweat-lodge and you know a lot
of different initiation rituals and
different grueling workouts and
different types of things founded come
all the different things there's nothing
that's come even close to an
approximation of the challenge of being
in an open relationship I mean if you're
saying you had a visceral reaction to
the description of the types of things
someone else of someone else doing it
like if I really if I really decided to
like break the break open the the walls
of privacy and share the details I mean
the people people get viscerally affect
like really viscerally affect because I
was I mean I've been in places where
I've been crawling around on the ground
and I know I mean if I should vomit or
cry or or like run or like punch a wall
or like there's so much feeling and yeah
like you said some of it I think is
conditioning and some of it is perhaps
in a program everything largely if I had
to put the scale I'd say it's largely
conditioning just based upon some of the
ancestral and tribal kind of
arrangements that we can find in you
know different groups around the world
but regardless like it's a brutal brutal
path and it's it's way way way harder
than you might think
no because I it in your book you say
about it right
dry retching on the floor for however
matter like half an hour or longer or
however long it was like the the maddest
thing was it doesn't surprise me the
whole incredibly challenging incredibly
challenging yeah say the least but
incredibly beautiful too you know and
that's the that's the thing because
through all those challenges that's
parts of yourself that you're breaking
open so that you can reheat you know
it's like if a bone if a bone forms
wrong you know you have to actually
rebate for it to form to like correctly
so that you're anatomically correct like
some parts of our ego have been formed
wrong and so you haven't have to like re
break the bone of the ego - then let
allow it to heal in its proper way but
the Reeb raking of the ego over and over
and over again and the Smashing of all
of that it's a it's a hell of a process
man but you start to get the hang of it
you know you start to get the hang of it
you start to realize like okay here it
comes
here comes the [ __ ] gigantic nut kick
from the universe like let me just
[ __ ] let me hold my breath you know
here's my testicles are gonna be about
throat high here and a few minutes and
and then just this is uh this is the way
it's going to go and you start
you know you start to just be ready to
learn the lessons and know that the
growth is gonna come on the other side
of that but I mean it's it's been
probably my greatest teacher of all the
things you know it's what's allowed me
to to learn the most about myself and
heal the most of my own needs for
validation and my own insecurities and
I'm not like hallelujah I'm healed you
know but I'm a hell of a lot closer than
when I started
and that interesting that one of the
greatest teachers of all of the
different things that you've done all of
the different experiences that you've
had hasn't been something that you've
done in solitude right yeah
it's been done in conjunction with you
know with the partner with Whitney in
particular and you know the other
relationships have taught me different
things and some of those things have
been valuable but it's the deep
emotional investment that I've had and
Whitney and the challenges that have
come from that deep emotional investment
that have really brought the greatest
level of gross I mean stress any type of
stress creates adaptation and too much
stress can create trauma that you don't
adapt from so like if you over trained
in the gym you'll actually get hurt and
not get stronger and I think we've
definitely put ourselves in positions
where we we've [ __ ] it up and like
overstressed ourselves and like created
traumatic patterns but nonetheless you
can learn to unwind those and learn to
take the space and time to heal those
but I think a well-executed open
relationship would have the pacing and
calibration there are two of the words
that they use a lot the pacing and
calibration to know that you're opening
up to challenge at a rate that you know
is actually just gonna allow you to move
through pretty consistently without
having to go back track and then unpack
a lot of trauma but we were doing this
kind of blind you know we were just kind
of figuring that out as we go and and
doing our very best so you know no fault
no fault on either side it's just that's
the way it uh that's the way it unfolded
but if we were gonna do it again we do
it a hell of a lot better than the first
time have you ever thought about doing a
course or contributing to a body of
knowledge somehow there's going to be
that's gonna be
third book for sure and it's gonna be
about you know what love you know in in
relationship can look like in like how
to reimagine love and relationship and
so you know I'm kind of holding off on
that right now Whitney is completely
holding that down she's offering
coaching she's got a great platform
right now so anybody interest you can
follow her at wit in love WH ite and
l.o.v.e and she's sharing all the wisdom
from our relationship and offering
coaching and she has a podcast called
true sex and wild love with Wednesday
Martin so she's really kind of diving
into that right now and I'm focused more
on mindset in the hero's journey for now
because quite frankly you know my my own
journey in learning about love is still
I'm still writing I'm still writing my
understanding I'm still understanding
what it looks like to be in this no
relationship relationship and then
ultimately like I said I'm pretty sure
that I'm gonna be engaging in a period
of celibacy and learning like okay
what's that what's that path look like
and like then ultimately trying to put
it all together but I'm not in any
position right now to say anything with
any kind of definitive definitive wisdom
Authority no authority on that because I
haven't really allowed all of this to
set in and explore it
I can certainly offer a lot of advice
from where I've been so far so people
who are you know interested in opening
their relationship but you know
Whitney's been there right along with me
for this whole journey and she's got a
great perspective so kind of allowing
her to take that thrust of information
as it is now and as mine continues to
mature that'll be a big focus for me in
the next five years or so that's cool
that's so getting back to our discussion
on the good life we've talked about some
guiding principles and some things that
people can cerebrally keep to give them
a North Star they're aiming toward but
anyone who's read James Claire's book
this year anyone who hasn't please go
and read atomic habits because it's
fantastic but he has this wonderful
quote in there which says we do not rise
to the level of our goals we fall to the
level of our
systems and I think that we need
structures and habits and routines to
instantiate the things that we want to
do so how do you instantiate the things
that make a life good to you what are
the structures that you lay your life
upon or some habits and some routines
that assist you to ensure you're doing
that well I think you got to take care
of the body you know that's what owned
the day on your life my first book was
about like you got to take care of the
body like this it's the low-hanging
fruit you know like if the body is out
of alignment the whole your whole
mindset is gonna be out of alignment
your everything's gonna be out of line
you're gonna be fighting an uphill
battle so handle that [ __ ] you know it's
it's a it's there's a lot of intricacies
but it's largely it's largely a solved
problem you know like stop [ __ ]
eating sugar like get some sleep
move you know move throughout the day
you know get some sunlight like drink
some saltwater
yeah hydrate there you go you know like
you're doing it like take care of your
[ __ ] you know and like get the basics
get the basics down and it doesn't mean
you don't need fancy supplements and
things like that you can add those if
you want to improve performance and all
that but it's just about like handling
the basics and then from there I think
it's about a personal ethos and that
ethos is if I see something that I'm
afraid of that or that something that I
know that there's work that I could do I
head towards it not away from it and
that's just a personal ethos so that
doesn't mean like actual danger doesn't
mean if there's like a black widow
spider in my shed I'm gonna go try and
touch it you know that's actual danger
that could hurt me you know like I'm
talking about emotional fears or these
things that are that I'm afraid of
exposing some insecurities that I have
the ethos that I have my own Warrior
Ethos is like oh I'm scared of that
that'll be hard okay I gotta go to do it
and that's again why I'm doing why I'm
doing this I'm probably gonna do this
I'm not gonna I don't want to commit
100% but I'm likely going to do this
celibacy thing it's just because I know
it's gonna be [ __ ] hard for me the
people the people in the internet now
will have thought there'll be something
clipped out of this that's just you so
in the word celibacy five times
right I don't blame you and I will
believe that it's that to interject
there there's this quote that I really
love and you might have heard it on
might not before and it's from Katherine
David Starr who's a CrossFit Games
athlete and the way that she talks about
discomfort is similar to yourself and
she refers to it as she says lean into
discomfort as if you'd invited it
through the door I really like that
analogy the fact as discomfort comes
towards you you lean into it you don't
shy away you don't stand your ground you
lean into it I really love that visual
it's the only way you know it's like if
you run away from your discomfort and
you its debt that thing is gonna chase
you down like a grizzly bear and you
know what a grizzly bear does when it
catches you it starts to eat you while
you're alive [ __ ] first that's what a
grizzly bear does so go ahead run away
from your fears and run away from those
things you're scared of but that grizzly
bears coming and when it gets you it's
gonna eat you [ __ ] first like so like
figure it out what your choice whatever
you want to do you know keep running
keep running keep running or stand your
ground and face it yeah you know okay so
we've got look after the body we've got
this ethos of facing up to things that
you're scared of what else I would say
community is another huge huge piece
you know like cultivating cultivating
and maintaining a healthy community and
that's people that you're comfortable
being real neural around and people who
you can share everything and people who
see you like I don't think we're able or
capable of doing this thing alone it's
too hard
life is just too hard to do it all by
yourself and I think people put so much
emphasis on your partner or like your
lover or this one person but really I
think that emphasis needs to be spread
much much wider out to your entire
community it's your community that
supports you because relationships come
and go and that's why I think people are
so devastated it's like she was my
everything well you [ __ ] up if she was
your everything you [ __ ] up
cuz that's like not a good strategy it's
you traded portfolio entirely 100% in
one stock all that 90% right a stock
right but that's the fantasy in the
fairytale that we're taught you're my
everything you complete me okay good
luck good luck with that you know hope
it goes perfect for you don't look at
the statistics cuz it's a really risky
bet you're making you know what I'm
saying but if you have it diversified to
a wide group of people that that'll all
share and love and vulnerability and and
things will get [ __ ] up with them too
you know like stuff will happen with
your friends you know like it's not like
they're infallible like even friendships
sometimes go through periods of
fluctuation less commonly so but it
happens so but like if you have if you
have a genuine community and many points
of of people who that you can talk to
about anything it's gonna help so so
much and I think so that to me adds
actually you know if we're talking it's
kind of interesting because you know
book one is about the body book two is
about the mind and the journey of
awakening your consciousness and mapping
that to the hero's journey book three is
gonna be about love and relationship and
book four is gonna be about community
because I think those are the four those
are like the four pillars of a good life
take care of the body you know
understand the mind and how to open it
up and look into your shadow you know
find the way that you can align yourself
to love and relationship that's invest
accord with yourself and then cultivate
and build the community and I think
those are the really the those are
really the principles and then you know
book five it's actually going to be
about alright now how do we apply this
everything that we've just talked about
so far how do we apply this globally to
the whole world you know like how what
would a world look like if we embraced
all of these principles and that's kind
of I am a genetic in fiction I'm gonna
have to really sharpen my pencil to get
my fiction game right but I keep going
to yeah yeah but that's but that's
really a really clear plan for me and it
really exemplifies those things that are
the most important to me in my life
is when you break life down into its
component parts like that it can seem so
simple it typically is that's the thing
it's just simple but it's simple but
hard you know that's like that that's
the truth like even though even like the
deepest spirituality is so simple but so
hard like you listen to ROM dasas ROM
dasas teacher yeah it is you know
Maharaja he said one thing he said love
everyone tell the truth all right that's
simple law of everyone tell the truth
well that's [ __ ] hard love everyone
tell for real like if you're gonna do
that that's hard you know and then like
ramadasu says love everything not every
being but everything I love my pain I
love my wheelchair I love like it's the
eradication of preference even because
you're loving everything well that's
simple but [ __ ] good luck good luck
pack a lunch because that shit's not
gonna be easy to get to you know what I
mean so I think I think a lot of the
deep wisdom is is very simple but
doesn't mean that it's easy to execute
it's something that people probably get
quite confused by the fact that a lot of
simple things are seen as easy
day-to-day life doing simple should be
easy but as you've said there because
simplicity has no room for a limited
room for nuance there's a limited room
for you to allow that eager to come in
and for it to change the rules if you
had loved everything but it was written
out and every individual thing you had
to love was stated and the document was
like the size of a law you'd be slippage
in between each of those things yeah but
it's exactly the simplicity is where the
difficulties derived from mmm you said
that beautifully man I was very very
well articulated and I think that's
absolutely right I think there's no it
doesn't leave you have any any room tell
the truth love everyone
well what does tell the truth even mean
that I'm like what how truthful is the
tree well it's the truth is the truth I
mean we're talking capital T here right
like we're not we're not making like
exceptions with lowercase T which is
tell like the convenient and you know
version of it it's like no tell the
truth love everyone you know love
everything like these are there's not a
lot of room there's not a lot of room to
wiggle around and mm-hmm
and that's why they're so powerful
talking about the truth it's something
which comes up all the time I was doing
a political podcast I was in London on a
political podcast and ended up talking
about the truth and why it's so
important for us people layer a lot of
in there a lot of personas and they're
able to hide their truth very
successfully and I've done it incredibly
well with very skillfully at some points
in my life and it's taken a lot of work
to unpack what that truth is I wondered
whether you had any advice for someone
who was potentially layered on top of
that truth so many personas that they're
struggling to find anymore
why you gotta you gotta catch on to
yourself and like I'm not I'm not much
different than you I recognize how
[ __ ] slippery I am because like the
ability to like justify and rationalize
and the create a story to make this true
this truth quotation mark true okay
seems yeah hello a case T quotation mark
asterisk italic yeah that you're
expressing like my ability to do that is
really it's really quite remarkable like
I can be really like really slippery
with how I can massage things and how I
can project things and and you know
there's some studies done that show that
like 55 percent of what you're
communicating is received by body
language 35 percent is received by
tonality and like less than ten percent
is received by the actual words that you
say so you could even be saying the
words but expressing them in an untrue
way
you know that's being manipulative and
so it's like you have to catch on to
yourself you have to like beyond here
like like realize like okay I see I see
you there Aubrey being slippery and
[ __ ] doing that thing you know I see
you projecting this air of confidence
even though your words are you know
quite vulnerable or vice versa you know
like it's it you just have to kind of
catch on to yourself and realize what
you're doing and that takes the
eradication first of all of shame like I
think I think that's a big thing that
limits us from seeing our truth and
being onto ourselves as being ashamed of
the truth and then also we have to let
go of our desire to manipulate selfishly
manipulate reality for our own interest
you know like truth truth is love tell
the truth and love everyone is actually
the same thing you know because you
can't love someone without telling them
the truth it's not it's a it's a
temporary it's a temporary ameliorate
it's like giving them it's like the
loving thing to do is not to give
somebody you know a candy bar it's to
give somebody like a healthy meal do you
know how many times I use that exact
analogy when I'm talking to people and I
relate it back to Jordan Peterson's be
friends with people who want the best
for you be friends with people that want
the best for you is not tell people what
they want to hear it's very often tell
people what they don't want to hear and
some of my best friends I can identify
the people who have my best interests at
heart because they don't swallow my
[ __ ] wholesale or part sale off
[ __ ] like micron scale they do not
think they don't let me get away with it
and yeah the the analogy is like a child
wants ice cream tea ice cream every
night like that's not what's good for it
but that is what it wants but doesn't
mean that's what it should get right
exactly exactly and it's just having the
having the patience even if there's a
little tantrum you know it's like I'm on
ice cream for dinner you know and you're
like I'm sorry sweetie like we're gonna
have
in chicken for dinner you know and it's
like now like you have to just hold to
hold that space and say mmm chicken is
best tonight you know what I mean
tonight today they'll be ice cream you
know for sure but like that is it is
having that the ability to just share
that with somebody and have them receive
it and to be able to withstand those
temporary reactions that people might
have because you know that it's the most
loving thing that you can do because
it's not enabling them to continue on
their own path of delusion we have to
understand that the our purpose here is
to wake up to the truth of who we are
and that all of the truth it's all
around us because that's all the love
that's all around us too and so if we're
all here to wake up to that truth and
we're shielding that truth from somebody
we're doing them a great disservice it's
a lot easier to be a good friend to
someone else than it is to yourself
though like the perspective the
perspective that we have when talking to
someone else I recently wrote an
Instagram post about this about the fact
that the likelihood of you ensuring that
your dog completes its course of
antibiotics is over 90%
the likelihood of you ensuring that you
complete your course of antibiotics is
under 50% and it tells us something very
interesting about how easy it is to care
for others and how difficult it is to
care for ourselves but this analogy that
a friend told me that stuck with me is
when you're in an airplane why are you
told to put your oxygen mask on first
because if you're suffocating you're a
very little use to everybody else around
you that's true yeah to be of service
you have to be fit for service that's
what my late spiritual teacher Don
Howard used to always say and that's the
that's the mastermind group that I
formed you the fit for service
mastermind base along that principle
like you have to take care of yourself
and you have to be overflowing with your
own abundance of energy love time
resources everything in order to
actually be observed true real service
to anybody or the world
and it begins with yourself I once had a
someone said where it came from but
someone says that in a in a healthy
relationship instead of serving someone
from your cup you actually serve them
from the overflow that fills the saucer
around the cup so that no one's actually
ever drinking from your own cup of your
own love and your own resource your
energy but you have so much that it's
always overflowing like a fountain and
filling the saucer and there's plenty to
drink from the saucer you know and then
that's like a really good metaphor I
think for how we have to take care of
ourselves because the moment our cups
empty well we're not going to be of any
use to anybody you know we're first of
all gonna be miserable but second of all
we're not gonna be helpful
anybody else heat it it's a Jordan
Peterson ism as well isn't it to pick up
the heaviest weight that you can and
bear it and then continue to do that and
you may be able to at first off carry
your own weight and then carry the
weight of the people around you and then
carry the weight of your community and
this hilarious idea that I think
progressive overload is king in every
domain from strength training to mind
training mmm yeah yeah yeah another
great way to put it so before we go all
right obviously we've got your books out
at the moment I want to know and I'm
sure a lot of people that are listening
I want to know what what are you working
on right now like what's a day in terms
of projects look like for you I mean I
think you know the podcast is something
that I really love so that's the Audrey
Marx podcast and then fit for service
mastermind I just recently mentioned
that's been just blown away all the
expectations of like forming a real
community around the ideas you know on
and of course continues to continues to
grow and beat its drum and its message
about you know being a little bit better
tomorrow than you are today and helping
the body and then you know I'm gonna
start writing my book my next book
coming up you know pretty soon here as
well and so that'll start to take up a
lot of time so there's always a lot of
lot of things in the works but you
nothing nothing too well and then was
the daily Instagram posts and everything
that I put out on that on that channel
as well so just just kind of doing all
the things man it's doing all the things
and just trying to learn learn and grow
yeah back to what I said at the start
very interestingly we actually I think
have been linked in the reason that
we've got this podcast happening is
because of Ross one of the guys who's in
your group and now uniform and episode
12 on this podcast was with mutual
friend and beautiful voice mr. Corey
Allen Corey's been on and Yammer I think
one of the things that does strike me as
very interesting is when someone is
working incredibly hard and incredibly
ruthlessly to try and sort out their own
[ __ ] and you have a very single sort of
linear focus in terms of how all of
these products are line you know you see
some entrepreneurs or professionals or
personalities however you want to to
name it and you look at the portfolio of
things that contribute to make up their
life in terms of where they invest their
time and you think these are quite
piecemeal here yeah
something from over there something from
over there and I don't really see how
this is one cohesive unit but I I can't
I can't really say that for yourself and
as well you know this episode is not
brought to you by on it however the only
nootropic that I've ever used which I
back is out of the brain and that's
thanks Donna Steven is one I need I
haven't used it tonight because my house
my house bit tight upstairs my house
smells like Oh John why do you have a
coffee now for brain outside it's 8 p.m.
I'm not a psychopath
like I'm have a coffee to a p.m. but
yeah what I need when I need that extra
that extra or kick it it really does
help and you know I think that having
someone who was in your position who is
pushing a more holistic view of the mind
a more complete view of how we should
progress as ourselves I think it's I
think it's something that's very
worthwhile and I'm looking forward to
seeing what you achieve over the coming
years
thank you brother I appreciate that man
and I always appreciate someone who has
a introspection and insight and it
surprises me with their own you know
mental machinations so keep doing what
you're doing man I'm doing doing good
work everything that we've spoken about
today from all brace book to his
Instagram undies fantastic podcast will
be linked in the show notes below of
course all right it's been awesome man
yeah likewise brother
[Music]
you